build it draw it play Vsauce Kevin here
with some of the coolest creations from
extraordinary people
this is PDP building Lee Heung Bo
creates paper illusions by gluing
together hundreds of sheets of paper the
flexible sculptures appear solid but
they can bend stretch fold or contract
his inspiration came from festive paper
gore's which are common decorations in
China and his most recent work involves
cutting silhouettes from butcher knives
students at MIT resurrected their old
tradition of incoming freshmen
constructing a wooden roller coaster
they were given a week to complete it
and initially plan to include a
loop-de-loop but were forced to scrap
that idea because the environment Health
and Safety Department said no upside
down students period Tim Baker built a
Groot swing the guardians of the galaxy
swing set was constructed from wood
metal and high-density foam Tim has been
a Hollywood set and prop builder for 25
years and the video is part of a new
superfan build series on the Omni
channel Victor pullin hand makes
boomerangs based on weapons from movies
and video games such as the glaive from
crawl hell's retriever from call of duty
black ops 2 and sokka's boomerang from
Avatar The Last Airbender he carves each
of them out of high-quality birch and
you can buy them on his website draw
Maria Malone Garba is a makeup artist
who can completely change her face using
nothing but face paint she's able to
transform into celebrities like Stevie
Wonder and Clint Eastwood fictional
characters like Elsa from frozen and
even animals like a baby seal Snow
Leopard and a reindeer aside from
working professionally on various TV
shows and movies she also teaches
workshops on the art of makeup mich
Goble creates abstract resin art to
support wildlife conservation
he's auctioning off 25 of his art pieces
that use a one-of-a-kind resin lacing
technique in order to raise money to
protect Australian rainforests and also
to fulfill his dream of starting his own
wildlife conservation calm
any and now the work of dougie who takes
iconic characters and reimagines them in
a trippy way
Geraldine Fenderson draws moving
pictures with sound using an analog
oscilloscope he sends sound into left
and right audio tracks to sculpt various
images like a mushroom forest complete
with a moving butterfly successfully
blending math science and art
quiet Sonia Bella Silva plays an
arrangement of the tetris theme on a
custom piano made from pinball machines
freak kitchens music video for freak of
the week is awesomely animated by former
Disney animator wonho horn Edo
Yukiko Shimano travels the world selling
her jewelry and playing the space drop
finally teenage exorcists by Mogwai
masterfully blends practical and visual
effects as directed by Craig Murray
inspiration also comes from you Vsauce
creative fan showcase first up is ESIC
with ghost towns let's go
Darius Hamilton hand paints custom shoes
for his website paint my soul calm he
uses high-quality leather paint and
takes specific requests from customers
after four years Jamie staff has
finished the Terminator t800
endoskeleton I featured the arm back in
BD P 45 and now the fully articulated
cast aluminum creation is complete Abe
and draws intricate doodles on eggs he's
an engineering student that creates the
artwork and photographs as a hobby
artifexian explains how to
mathematically build a plausible binary
star system like Tatooine from Star Wars
last step is to place your gas giant
habitable worlds and then find all the
other orbits in the system
here's Nia wigs with release the Kraken
part 1
gropey is a circuit and app that turns
your phone into a robot created by Edwin
John on his bedroom floor he's made the
circuit public for everyone to use
here's some fractal artwork from a tea
Brian Carter builds a minecraft
Christmas tree with the control system
for RGB LEDs that change the color on
his actual Christmas tree which is
awesome
submit your bidipis to BD p @ vsauce
comm or share them with everyone on
twitter with hashtag BD p and as always
thanks for watching
you